hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen endlich mal wieder zu einer
neuen folge vize biest okay was heißt
endlich hat jetzt einen tag pause weil
wir keine zeit gefallen haben weil ich
24 stunden durchgängig dfb-pokal geguckt
habe fußball fußball sagt unser fußball
experte und gespielt er hofft dass über
raten wir was gespielt habt was auf ich
weiß ich weiß dass bayern gegen dortmund
gespielt hat und ich sag mal ich habe
nicht mitbekommen dass quer gefordert
mit ich schwöre ich hab davon nichts
mitbekommen weil ich lebe wie
abgeschotteten nach außen will also ich
glaube erlebt wie abgeschottet in der
außenpolitik
also ich glaube also ich sag mal so
beyer hat eine mannschaft die teurer ist
auf jeden fall weil die mehr geld haben
aber dortmund ist man auch gut die haben
doch letztes jahr den mal die ich glaub
der im letzten jahr gewonnen
am letzten grün gut okay dann sag ich
einfach mal was bist du vent bayern oder
dortmund bayern
okay dann sag ich einfach mal dass
bayern gewonnen hat wie hoch 22.11.10
haben sie gewonnen
durch ein tor von arjen robben acht der
holländer ja ich weiß was du übrigens da
wir jetzt und konstanten server haben
guck mal dass die romane schon grün ja
wir tilgen habt ihr das zwar nicht
mitbekommen aber da wir jetzt eine woche
oder so nicht aufgenommen haben und bei
wärme länger aufnehmen ist jetzt ne
menge grün nimmt diesmal zwar nur zwei
folgen auf das heißt für euch wieder
zeit ganz ganz viele kommentare zu
schreiben was wir dann auch beachten
werden ich habe ja auch gerade wieder
eine mail aufgemacht aber danach werden
wir dann am wochenende ist wieder ganz
lange aufnehmen und dann wir können das
eigentlichen weg machen aber kommt mitte
kurzem simon
ich habe hier so viel wie sophie energy
dosen und wenn ich jetzt laut schreien
oder wenn ich dort rede dann halt das in
meinen dosen richtige nervig
hinter des jahres kommt eigentlich sogar
relativ cool aus mit dem mit dem erst
beim 1 besonders so sondern es extra so
zu also die absicht so zu wachsen das
aber nur von dieser seite will ich sein
und dann müssen die fenster hier weg
machen und denen wir müssen die
komplette baum fahren nochmal ein
bisschen eingrenzen
weil du hast sie so um
metrisch gebaut wir könnten ja auch so
ein brauner und sind niedrig was laberst
du ja da hab ich hier so einen zaun drum
war von andy baum fahren hast du gelernt
genau symmetrisch guck dir sagen ja aber
diese bäume diese baureihe hier die
könnte auch einfach hier stehen wir hier
dann steht sie da genau damit sondern
pastors wenn die waffen sicher was sagen
was denn da ich meine mutter ja was
statt den kleinen wieder aufkommen
kommissar den kleinen schwedischen den
kopf hab da kommen ja was willst du hast
du kleiner ruhe an
du bist ein kleiner ruhe an
derzeit können schreiben die
kommentatoren ist ne lass uns die kunden
dafür und geschrieben wenn ich den
obersten hoch verlieren sind die man ja
eine person geschrieben hat die
allerdings nicht allerdings ich wollte
dass ich seine email nenne ich das
erstmal und dabei könnt ihr sie mal zu
gucken wer da hinten skript auf der
einen seite des busses
erstens der generator produziert aus
brennmaterial zum beispiel kohle holz
also wir müssen da kohle und so weiter
macht er auch irgendwas so und irgendwas
auch immer gestimmt wir dürfen die
sachen den ich wieder abbauen
das heißt wir brauchen dafür erst seine
spezielle spitzhacke erst mal das
komplette wasser kohle oder gas kohle
und zwar können nur wird mir geschrieben
dass die chinesen einfach in extractor
packen können
damit ist erst mal ganz kurz weil das
sind 10 11 punkte stellt der base rate
zerkleinert ärzte zu pulver / staub
zum beispiel ein eisenerz retter gibt
zwei eisen staub dabei ist dass der
mieter hat es da unten gucken wir
einfach cool ab 1
das geht wohl die tamis machen hat muss
man da rein packe meine rennen egal wo
ein staub erhält man offenbaren das
heißt dieses staub hat man dann in den
ofen kriegt man waren also bekommt man
aus einem eher 2 barren und der
elektrischen ofen muss genauso wie der
meister mit strom aus dem generator
versorgt versorgt werden das heißt wir
müssen so kupferkabel da hinterher legen
am besten fall bestenfalls oder da
vorher dann der elektrischen ofen ist
schneller als ein normaler offen das
hier ist unser elektrischer offen da wo
ich jetzt gerade drauf stehe ihr könnt
euch die kabel sparen indem ihr dem
generator in der mitte positioniert und
links und rechts davon betroffen
kevin ritter links naja egal wir können
den hier den electric ferner sehr
einfach hier einstellen müssen wir ihnen
die abbauen und eine hochwertige biest
maschinen nur mit einem
schraubenschlüssel ranch abbauen sonst
können sie möglicherweise zerstört
werden also wir brauchen rasch das kann
ich gleich mal machen das kann man ja
suchen in diesem menü natürlich noch
etwas der energie wird im generator
gespeichert um mehr strom zu speichern
eine black box oder ein mrt oder eine e
mails ehesten kräften diese speicher
über kupferkabel das kompliziert erzählt
euch ein freundlicher jetzt das
allerwichtigste
schaut euch einen baut euch einen ex
traktor damit könnt ihr aus rabat
stickerei sie machen aus dem gummi
rubber machen könnt beschäftigt euch
doch bitte mal mit rail und train kraft
also danke bestimmte personen namens fan
und helfer tobi okay okay danke für
diese menge genau so muss es sein und
erinnert jetzt schritt hat uns bitte
folgen weil wir haben da jetzt so
accounts und da könnt ihr dann so dinge
sind also wir haben das fcb lp und dann
schreibt uns einmal sachen das habe ich
auch gerade helfen
lukas basler hat geschrieben du bist mit
conny zusammen der westlb wäre doch das
ist so hilfreich wenn ich heute
wahrscheinlich dass andere seien hier
simon fraser hat geschrieben
hey hey ich will meine tipps geben und
zwar solltest solltet ihr ein extra
extractor bauen
der holt aus allen rabatt sorten das
rabatt raus dann müsst ihr nur noch holz
hacken und nicht auf stick gisin achten
wird mich über eine antwort freuen
ja ich hab ich hab mir niemand rede
betont kogler mehr viel zeit als freddy
32 aber genommen ich hab ich das weil
ich sonst getötet wenn du rettest jungen
aber auch in bronze auf jeden fall wir
brauchen bronze ins sonst kann es keine
ranch france oder mal zu kupfer bronze
bronze bronze guckt du kannst einfach
mal ranch eingeben
ich mache gar nichts was du mental
außerdem meiner arbeit ab ja ich möchte
meine fahren jetzt erst mal bauen
bronze-rang fürbitte jetzt bei coop eg
was der sonne
damit kommen wir denn noch so bei uns
sondern da habe ich die verarbeiter
wollen wir haben bronze putz und sowas
ja darfst du aber wie komme ich an
bronze
ich habe bronze blog gesehen und
das passiert nicht scheren nehme und
roland theoretisch habe ich noch länger
zeitweilig schneit gerade der wie
draußen im feld fußball wahrscheinlich
aus ich hab allerdings muss kurz vor 18
uhr noch mal wieder in hamburg eine
stunde gut dann vorzeitig ich werde die
baum fahren hier die die familie ein
bisschen umbauen
toller trainer will jetzt live bei
twitter dabei hey das voll cool so was
denkt jemand machen so lange am leben
weil sollten wir sollten bitte mal sowas
ankündigen wo wir schreiben so jetzt
spiele vize biest hier komme ich gerade
ausnahme fdp elke habe ich vor zehn
minuten geschrieben ja cool gut woher
kriegen wir bronze
ja das ist eine gute sache conny das ist
richtig schön gut die seiten fragen hey
das ist freude geil von der ich bin
jetzt 70 geschlagen
und wenn ich dann später so geile wird
das internet habe dann wenn ich wieder
zwei bildschirme habe dann ist auch geld
hab zwei bist die kleine habe außerdem
was kaputt ich hab was du bist gemacht
ich hab wasser hier so blöd gesetzt
sobald das wasser so und erläuterte
minuten später allerdings empfehlen in
seinem twitter programm oder so weil ich
habe genutzt es immer beim browser und
ich habe ganz gut weg und spielt gut und
alles mögliche gibt es ja für handy oder
was oder ist ein neuer tun will
anscheinend so beliebt wie du dachtest
nicht auf die werden da gar nicht
eingehen
nach korn crafter hat jetzt übrigens
100.000 abonnenten seit einiger zeit
ich sollte das mal ansprechen die das
thema ist eigentlich auch genannte
youtube 800 war schon folie abonnenten
das habe ich immer die geschichte
erzählt wie wir uns erst mal begegnet
sind die arrogante was mir war das
projekt mit dir machen wenn du jetzt
wenn nicht so arrogant
du bist kein bretten wir machen
vielleicht will ich dann kriegen wir
machen das letzte folge doch was du
willst nicht bei den schwachen
sollte also ich sag mal so ich möchte
euch mal ganz wichtig wie viele minuten
habe sie erst vorbei ist erfahrt ihr in
der nächsten und ich und konkreter
zusammengefunden haben und warum ich ihn
erst für sehr einem romantischen warum
ich ihn erst für sie aufrecht gehalten
habe und das nach einer kurzen
unterbrechung von einem tag aber denkt
daran auf einem kanal vielmehr wie oder
ich hab einfach jetzt direkt von zwei
videos leute falls erst guckt heute kaum
noch zwei andere videos einmal richtig
fett pvp und heute täglich das neue
unpacked da gibt's übrigens auch nicht
da ist
hier so richtig schön skins sind alle
schon dann läuft er direkt dadurch wenn
ich so christa bauer vom weg mit dir
ok ich muss sagen der nächsten wir
machen erstmal ein bisschen wir jetzt
hier ist also das war die erste folge
ist vollgestellt simon ich kann ich ja
weiß warum bei kompakter das papier kann
ich gar nicht kriegen
du bist auch nicht gut man kann ich
sagen pvp oder so meinke pvp man muss
einfach nur schlecht
lasst uns nicht ab 2 30 levels welche
pro wertvolle leben was du hast lange
gefallen
da kann ich es wieder junge dass das
war's zu 100 von ihren ich hab gesagt
konkrete glaubst du bist hinten
gesprungen die schlucht runter alter
halt die fresse jetzt nicht alle hier ja
das sind nicht alle ja weißt du auch
sagen wer hat hier angefangen herr junge
tu was angefangen du bist bei mir
durchschlagen gelaufen dadurch abbauen
ja das abbauen wir geschlafen aber du
wolltest an den krieg ich wollte den
kriegen das okay das war die erste runde
wieder viel zu bieten scheint hause ein
bisschen mehr action hier und der
nächsten folge erfahrt ihr warum
kontostand ich zuerst einen nicht so gut
veränderten und er dann trotzdem nicht
berühren wollte das erfahrt ihr alles in
der liste aufnahm
franziskus mit ok